[Musique]
si le jeudi est un jour de détente et de
joie pour les enfants valides
il n'en n'est pas toujours de même pour
les jeunes handicapés pour pallier leur
isolement
l'association des paralysés de france a
créé des clubs de jeudi depuis huit ans
un peu partout en france 35 ans tous là
il se retrouve qu'on dit me grâce à la
gentillesse des loisirs et d'un haut
rhin l'autre à va passer comme ça il va
revenir là et donc il faudra de changer
puisqu'il sort de la wii loisirs l'on
n'oublie pas il y a un gars à chaque
fois que le train déraille il ya un gage
nous avons rencontré tant que les
animateurs de ce club à paris xavier
bertrand ont l'habitude de croire que
les si les enfants sont paralysés il
faut leur donner et des jeux faciles et
des jeux même qui ne correspondent pas à
leur âge et à leur mentalité
alors que je crois que c'est
complètement fou plus le jeu est
difficile et surtout plus le jeu se
rapportent à des jeux de garçons plus
ils sont heureux et plus il anime comme
ça avec moi le club du jeudi
je me souviens par exemple d'un garçon
paralysé on lui a demandé est-ce qu'il
regrettait le plus dans sa vie il a
toujours répondu que c'était de ne pas
pouvoir taper dans un ballon et pendant
quelques fois les séances on les fait
jouer au ballon avec des louveteaux avec
des scouts
est ce qu'ils veulent c'est même s'ils
ne peuvent pas pouvoir taper un petit
peu dans un ballon même si pour ça il
faut le faire avec la avec lâchait ça ne
les ennuie absolument pas ils sont pas
du tout complexe est pas absolument
ils ont même des travaux manuels assez
nombreux et galway et ils s'entassent et
finalement assez habile et ils sont pas
du tout gêné de voir qu'il ya certaines
choses bien sûr qu'ils ne peuvent pas
faire les autres il en aperçoive mais
ils n'en parlent pas ils sont beaucoup
plus détendue ici parce qu'ils se
retrouvent entre garçons de l'orage et
parce que je crois on essaye justement
de leur donner des jeux qui ne met pas
du tout en valeur ou en évidence leur
paralysie
on les considère comme des garçons tout
à fait normaux mais ils vont tous de
toute façon en classe dans des écoles
tout à fait normal tout ça les personnes
qui n'ont pas de difficultés oui vous
êtes étudiant je crois oui oui qu'est-ce
qui vous a mené au récent qui paie de
cela et bien je suis routier à janson de
sailly et c'est par le scoutisme que
notre aumônier à contacter est madame
foucault qui s'occupe des paralysés de
france et qui nous a fait appel parce
que généralement nous cherchons un
service alors certains de mes camarades
ont visité des enfants dans des hôpitaux
d'autres s'occupent des
des vieillards et puis nous non mais ne
sommes pas du tout est spécialisée dans
dans cette branche
[Musique]
mais si en province les clubs sont
souvent mixtes ceux de paris ne le sont
pas madame flocco responsable pour la
région parisienne parle de filles les
filles elles
elle souhaite retrouver ce qu'elle
aurait fait là encore si elles avaient
été bannis zh
contrairement à ce que l'on croit au
lieu que ça donne ça les rend triste
je suis prêt à intégrer dans la vie
courante ça répond à un besoin
c'est en quelque sorte une compensation
ça leur donne envie d'agir plus celle
ordonnée envisagée ça leur donne envie
de voir vraiment qu'elle voit jour
l'impression qu'elles font comprenez oui
oui oui exactement
très intéressant de voir que ces enfants
veulent absolument près ce que je peux
dire prouver qu'ils sont capables de
faire nous s'ils ne font pas aussi bien
en tout cas avec autant d'enthousiasmé
que les autres et ils veulent absolument
être classé dans la société ça ça me
fait absolument pas de problème mais je
pense que c'est surtout ça qui est
attirant de voir ses enfants bien sûr
qu'on peut aider mais surtout qu'on sent
évoluer et avec beaucoup de courage et
avec beaucoup de vitalité
[Musique]